mir ist klar dass du vorhin gesagt hast
du nimmst die auszeichnung
stellvertretend gegenüber geschäftlich
soldaten und soldaten im einsatz
entgegen
allerdings ist schon faktum dass wenn
robert kratky drauf steht auf dem video
und doch wesentlich mehr leute sich
schön video anschauen und das ja auch
ein hauptgrund dafür war dass man weiß
heute bekommen hat woher kommt für diese
verbindung zu google her
da muss man auch da war hätte ergeben
ursprünglich war das ein war das ein
auftrag so wie ich halt aufträge mache
irgendwie wenn ich das gefühl habe dass
es in irgendeiner weise nahe steht 1 1
gestanden ist mir das bundesheer schon
einen deshalb weil ich wohne in der
roten zone also für alle da nichts
anfangen können das ist das ist ein
wohngebiet wo zum beispiel in meinem
fall die donau ab und zu mal ins hause
bin einfach auch zu hause wo das
bundesheer immer wieder mit einem
unglaublichen einsatz geglänzt hat
menschen und und das was sie sich ihr
leben lang gearbeitet haben gerettet
oder bewahrt hat also meine dankbarkeit
gegenüber dem dänischen bonus er kam
schon sozusagen von hause aus im
wahrsten sinn des wortes
deswegen war als damals der anfrage von
von tagen zu bekommen ist für mich das
relativ klar dass das etwas ist was war
das nicht gut zu mir passt und ich passe
ganz gut dazu jeweils hier tatsächlich
einfach eine verbindung gibt
meine verbindung davor war einfach nur
am ende acht monate bei den linien in
salzburg und im mini kommando in wien
und die diese monate man schon sehr
lange aus aber ich habe gesehen was das
bundesheer kann quasi vor der haustür
und deswegen war das war das für mich
gar keine gar keine große frage aber das
machen möchte ja gesagt naja was heißt
viele von den soldatinnen soldaten
wachen ja schon seit vielen jahren mit
mir auf oder oder für für manche haben
wir dann
ich wäre sogar eine kindheitserinnerung
und ich habe das gefühl gehabt als es um
die jeweiligen anforderungen für jede
folge ging an mich dass auch viele
soldatinnen soldaten einmal ausprobieren
wollten was sie wirklich aus heute weil
jemand so cool in der früh also die
wollten mal die probe aufs exempel
machen und einige haben sie
wahrscheinlich auch für ständige
aufwecken revanchieren wollen
also ich wurde sehr gefordert und da ist
es natürlich zu sehr vielen situationen
gekommen wo wir dann hinterher gelacht
haben währenddessen und entsorgen
eine eine auszeichnung die auszeichnung
alleine ganz ehrlicherweise wäre jetzt
noch nicht der punkt hinter dieser
auszeichnung steht ja was hinter der
auszeichnung steht der erfolg einer
eines gemeinsamen projekt der geradezu
unglaublich war also ich hab 4,2
millionen fans allein auf youtube nicht
mit eingerechnet was die presse
berichtet hat das licht in dem plötzlich
soldaten unserer garten mit ihrer
täglichen arbeit und ihrem können
gestanden sind
das war der eigentliche erfolg dieser
geschichte und in dem fall pan sich hier
die auszeichnung von der frau
bundesministerin mit auf der anderen
seite der eigentlichen auszeichnung
nämlich diesen unglaublichen erfolg für
jene die ihn verdient haben nämlich die
soldaten und so so so glänzt diese
medaille natürlich für mich schon
besonders weil für mich wissentlich ein
zeichen dass hier etwas wahnsinnig gut
funktioniert hat aber das lag wie gesagt
sicherlich nicht alleine an mir weil das
alter ansprichst naja also rein
statistisch gesehen hätte hätte ich
jetzt glaube ich noch 30 jahre vor mir
also zahlt sich durchaus noch aus für
mich halt nur milch zu kaufen
ja und ich hätte eigentlich schon noch
ein paar dinge vor im leben aber aber
wenn es das jetzt gewesen sein soll dann
gehe ich zumindest mir der name der mann
ist ja aber das war es noch nie das ist
das leben das leben gibt immer wieder
überraschungen manchmal auch das ende
des selbigen und ich dafür gesagt dass
tatsächlich jetzt auch noch einmal an
alle soldatinnen soldaten die das hier
sehen und sich denken war wieso kriegt
es war wirklich ich nehme sie
stellvertretend für die vielen die
mitgemacht haben
tagwache mit grad danken wir euch allen
ganz herzlich die hat oder bei wort die
ebenbild war es aber auch im hintergrund
mitgeholfen habe es bei der organisation
ihr habt es unglaubliche erfolge erzielt
waren sich viele menschen haben euch
gesehen stellvertretend für die vielen
vielen an und nicht zu sehen waren aber
tagtäglich ihre arbeit machen und dafür
gab es im mitteilen
reich